let's think of some numbers that really
aren't integers okay because I think
this might be a little bit easier okay
let's think of some numbers so people
did say is not an integer because it's
made up from parts of other numbers yeah
okay these are all decimals these are
all decimals are there any other kinds
of numbers we could use yeah both fine
both not integers okay um I'm not sure
you guys impermissibly probably did a
little bit of work with circles
didn't you know making circles is a
funny number that comes up with circles
it's so funny we don't even have an
English character for does it order go
to is that yeah it's a great it's a
Greek letter we're gonna be doing a lot
of work with Pi so if you've never seen
it before that's okay we're gonna be you
know I but it's short for 3.14159265 six
don't be pressed I defer to memorize
introduced but whatever it is it ain't
whole there was a stain the US that
tried to actually pass law to say let's
let pie equal to three unfortunately
they were role so that battle wasn't
passed which is a good thing it's my
home I'll throw one more number actually
which is a bit tricky because I'm not
sure if everyone's better if you haven't
it's okay when will be adjusted later as
they don't see this sign what's it
called
that's called the square root right what
is it short for if I would put say let's
put 16 then what's the square root of 16
what does it mean to say is rather 16
it's something multiplied by itself
squares and you get 16 which in this
case is 4 now for is its Gernot these
right so that's not that's that is an
integer but that's not I don't know what
it is on the top my head but it's gone
okay you can go you can work it out
it'll be something it'll be 3.8
something something okay but it won't be
integer okay
of course we should make something
negative okay now let me teach you a
fancy phrase I want you to write me if
you have already write these down is
your examples of introduced what these
are are what we call counter examples a
counter example is an example of
something that's not okay so these are
examples of integers these are examples
all not integers